[موسيقى]
تعتبر علاقه العشائر بالدوله العراقيه منذ
تاسيسها رسميا عام
1921 امرا جوهريا اذ كانت الطبيعه
العشائريه للمجتمع العراقي طاغيه في مطلع
القرن العشرين
فاكثر من 70% هم ابناء الريف وعشائرهم في
كثير من الاحيان كانت للعشائر العراقيه
ادوار مهمه ومواقف حاسمه في المحافظه على
السلم الاهليه وبسط الامن مثلما حدث بعد
الانفلات الامني الكبير عام 2003 بعد
احتلال العراق ودوري العشائر في تحرير
العراق من احتلال داعش عام 2014 لكن فيما
بعد اخذ دور العشائر منحا اخر يختلف عن
هذه الادوار في بعض الاحيان فكلما ضعفت
الدوله كلما اكتسبت العشيره قوه وم
والعكس صحيح
احنا ما مثلا طالعين باجره ولا مثلا احنا
جايبين
القران قد ذكر القبائل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم وجعلناكم شعوبا
وقبائل لتعارفوا الى اخر الايه
العشائر منذ القدم موجود انا اعتبر
العشيره كحكومه صغيره ولكن
كل فتره
تختلف عن اختها الاخرى